I think fish is meat because it's an
animal right it's efficient that yeah
it's an animal what is an animal a fish
is an animal an animal is anything with
the sole right I think I'm really on a
tangent here I don't even know we're
still talking about nasacort right
[Music]
though GQ actually it's the people who
watch GQ hi I'm Dave and I'm a rapper
who's goes by little Dicky and these are
my essentials can't live without them
[Music]
first things first warmth I've got this
here blanket that is cream-colored I run
cold as a human you touch my hands at
any moment you know you might be shocked
that y'all think I'm sick so I put this
blanket on me just to keep my blood
warmth up it's not this blanket only
like this is not like my childhood
blankie I never had a blankie I guess
now I do have a blankie but this point
here has a good texture to where I
bought like four different versions of
it different colors scattered around the
house two people can fit under this I
will wrap it around women when we're
watching movies brings bodies closer
together in a totally consensual good
way nothing weird going on over here I
can't even express how important these
headphones are to me I actually can't
even make music without using these
heads it's like a very I they're so worn
I've worn them down if you can see the
like gristle of the phone and they're
worn down in such a way that it actually
totally impacts like the Sonics of
everything and it's the only way I care
to hear my own voice when I record which
is totally problematic like if I lost
these headphones I really don't know
that I'd be able to make music anymore
I'm definitely like being I know that is
true yeah if I lost the headphones I
think I'd have to retire I doubt that
like the more a headphone exists the
better it gets I think it's pretty
counterintuitive I today just in this
case I don't know it's hard to explain I
don't know like the phrasing or the
words I do but there's a sharpness to my
voice that if I had the brand-new
version of these like it gets much
duller and I need to feel not dull
because if I don't like the way I sound
when I'm rapping who will when I put
these on I like really respect myself
just like when I'm like you know
freestyling and I hear my own voice I
think oh my god you really are like the
one that's what I look like when I wear
them the cord itself disposable
got ten of these doesn't matter which
quarter in fact this toward sack is too
long there's no reason I should might
ever have a cord this long it's actually
a burden when I freestyle it actually
makes no sense ever it's like I don't
understand how rappers can go in the
booth and like freestyle but jay-z like
actually freestyles brilliant pros when
I freestyle it's just like gibberish a
freestyle about my experience at GQ okay
Here I am today at GQ earlier I farted
PU I call this the zone it's a white
noise machine I call it the show because
it's made by Joan every night I sleep
with this white noise machine on it just
sounds like for the whole eight hours
and it's so important I've slept with a
with the noise machine my entire life I
don't like silence like you hear every
creak I think you hear your own thoughts
more perhaps maybe I just want to like
feel nothing I'm like about to sleep I
want to just hear just women sometimes
will sleep over and initially be very
resistant of the white noise sound
they'll say this is unbearable I can't I
don't even want to be here anymore and
by the morning they'll say I'm getting
one for my own house because I had such
a great time with you I think part of it
is because of your personality another
part of it might be because of your zone
man
initially I purchased this neck pillow
for flights but there's something that's
so economically unsound about my studio
setup at home combined with my frail
like just spine and posture choices that
makes it an absolute requirement for me
to wear this when I rap and record this
is like my natural posture look at how
it is without
I'm doing this birth for our strain
right I did my best rapping at like 9:30
a.m. fresh out of the shower contact
lenses in I'm seeing clearly there's two
screens up and then around like 1:00
p.m. I'll notice a soreness in my neck
only from holding my head up I put this
on and from about like 1:30 to 6:00 I'm
wearing this half the music you'll ever
hear from me when I'm recording it it's
like me wearing this thing you should
know that it doesn't take away any of
the swag you think it might actually
adds value I feel more like a performer
when I wear it it's like a futuristic
thing you know how like Nelly had like
the band aid people used to wear like
goggles
you know chains even this is kind of my
thing I think it's not really like
making waves yet but we're doing this
piece and maybe more people will see it
nasacort seems pretty self-explanatory
but no one can really rap effectively
with the stuff nose my nose is just
always stuff one time I went to the ENT
that your nose and throat doctor and he
couldn't believe that I live life this
way my nose is stuff to that 95% of the
time I can't even smell I have no sense
of smell and sometimes it gets stuffed
just such a degree that I can't even
breathe so I can't rap that way again so
this is like this is I probably put too
many sports in you know it says I think
uses doesn't even say the amount you
should or should not use I know you
shouldn't be doing like eights quarts a
day on each nostril so I spray it and it
clears me up at least momentarily and
there's no residual like odor I've taken
other versions of this and there's this
like taste no not with nasal court
[Music]
where do I begin it is Harry he's an
alien one of the best friends I'll ever
have he's been around since I was 8 and
I'm 31 so you know I'll do the quick
math real quick so 23 23 years big nose
mouth underneath I draw him a lot like
if I was at a restaurant and they were
like crayons and napkins to draw on for
children I would draw Harry what he also
doesn't talk like I don't actually
believe that he is a real thing but it
doesn't mean he's not important my cream
every night
you're probably wondering what's this
guy doing at 9:30 p.m. is he in the gym
getting shots ah is he collaborating
with like Kanye West no putting cream on
my face I don't know what it does but
I'm normally so greasy but you know
those things that yeah that like you buy
it like a Walgreens where it's like a
thin sheet of plastic and you put it on
your face and it becomes clear and you
can see how much grease you have before
this cream if I put that on my face the
the sheet would evaporate like you would
actually like it would evaporate due to
the grease I'm so greasy press your
finger on my head and you're disgusted
until this cream morning apply the cream
night apply the cream you know I think
you can see facially like I'm certainly
coming into my own I'm like really I
think thriving romantically sexually and
I'm just ready to explode in 2020
so recently somebody sent me an oculus
the tool that allows you to enter the
three dimensional realm you know I knew
there were like games to play on it and
whatnot but the first thing I did like
I'm sure everybody does is I looked into
like VR porn that's the only reason this
is here III don't do anything but watch
porn on this I don't I know there's like
a lot of cool things you can do I'm sure
there's something great I could do with
like the NBA like feel like you're
courtside but really know this thing
comes into play around
of 12:30 a.m. every night and it's a
real to do you know there's so many it's
it's crazy it's really cool
people were saying don't do this it's
good you're gonna disappear from the
face of the earth you're gonna stop
dating no it has not replaced actual
like romance or women it's just replaced
two-dimensional masturbation water
bottle seems simple but it's a constant
because first off the worst thing that
can ever happen to somebody I think is
that they're thirsty I think like you
mean if you died of thirst that would
suck so I stand by that comment
I think being thirsty is horrible
obviously we're in the middle of a huge
environmental crisis and like we
shouldn't have plastic bottles around at
all times that's so wasteful so I've got
this old I call it my pink thing and
fill it up with water it's um the
technology isn't the same the water is
cold it stays cold forever in this thing
I could have cold water in it in the
fridge take it out put it in the desert
I think actually I'm not sure but it
should I think it should thirsty right
now actually like it just came out of
the fridge last thing is already here
and it's my body and I'm just kidding
it's in my rubber band that I keep on my
left wrist at all times ever since I was
in fifth grade I used to wear the hair
bands of girls that I had a crush on but
it actually turned kind of territorial I
wanted to wear my hair band so just to
keep everybody satisfied I started
wearing just the whole foods rubber band
on my left wrist I've had a wholefoods
rubber band on my left wrist for about
17 straight years not the same one they
stretched out one will last about three
weeks before it gets too loose and full
of lint
there are times we're like I'll do a
concert or something and I'll crowd surf
you know because I'm cool and somehow
like the rubber band will get like
ripped off my wrist and then like I
won't like realize it until like two
hours later and I'll be shocked and feel
so uneasy until I can get another one on
my wrist people think that I wear it
till I do the you know the self
correction thing know and I hate boy oh
I hate when people come up to me and go
like boots news4 and stretch it out
happens all the time
I want to spit in the person's face when
they do that but I don't because I'm
well-adjusted thanks GQ these are my
essentials I'm not saying that you need
to do what I do but obviously I have
like reached like a pinnacle in terms of
success and if you want to adopt the
things that I do they'll go for it I
think it's cool and thanks for watching
I was cool
[Music]